a former Chicago police officer risked
her life and her career to expose a
massive criminal ring in her own
department think about that for a second
undercover narcotics officer name is
Shannon Spalding says fellow cops were
planting drugs and extorting people
living in a housing project but despite
her fear of retaliation she and her
partner reported them to their
Department and the FBI former judge
police officer and host of CBS's
whistleblower series Alex Ferrara went
to Chicago to talk to Spalding for the
season two premiere it was a full-blown
war every single day soon after joining
the Chicago Police Department in 1996
Shannon Spalding drew an assignment in
one of the most violent neighborhoods in
the city it was like a movie set it was
shocking off for me it was just a
completely different world to survive
Shannon leaned on veteran cops like
Ronald Watts I thought he was battling
crime and he was doing it with finesse
and grace in 2006 a decade after Shannon
Spalding was trained by watts
she had a new assignment in the
Narcotics Division I was the undercover
I would go out I would make the
controlled narcotics purchases her
partner Danny echeverria would swoop in
and make arrests but during police
interviews something strange started
happening people would say I can't
believe you're gonna arrest me when one
of your own is actually running the
narcotics trade Shannon learned Watts
and his crew would plant drugs on
residents of the Ida B Wells projects
and extort cash even the good citizens
that live there that are law-abiding
citizens they're subjected to this we
heard people put anything from a couple
bags to enough to put you away for 10 15
20 years
in 2006 I to be Wells resident Dolores
Allen witnessed this practice firsthand
when her son's Eric was pushed up
against watts police car he goes in his
pocket brings out the drugs if you guys
I catch y'all again I'm gonna put these
drugs on your that's his exact words
Dolores says watts kept his word later
that year Zarek was arrested and charged
with felony possession of heroin and
crack cocaine he was 17 years old
Dolores says the drugs were planted by
watts I just saying all this hopes and
dreams and stuff just it just went down
to Jeff from there Shannon and her
partner would eventually learn what's
bad deeds had been going on for years if
we don't report this criminal conduct
we're absolutely no better than Watts
or any of these other corrupt officers
and if we do we may just be ending our
careers putting ourself in real danger
so what did you and your partner decide
to do I convinced him that we needed to
go to the FBI and my greatest fear was
because this was such a long-running
criminal enterprise I felt that we would
be set up for dead Shannon Spalding and
her partner spent years undercover
investigating Ronald watts and his team
with the help of that investigation more
than 60 people wrongfully arrested by
watts and his team were later exonerated
that includes a young man that you just
met in the story is Eric Johnson
Alex Ferrara joins us at the table to
discuss good to see you Alex first I'd
say thank you to Shannon Spalding number
one amazing amazing woman did she bored
did she get any backlash Oh a better
question is how much backlash she was
she lost her career she had attempts on
her life she it was just devastating
when you watch tonight's episode the
roller coaster of emotions from the the
people who were wrongfully convicted
some of them did ten years in prison for
crime they didn't commit you know and
and her coming forward against this this
code of silence I'm a former police
officer myself you know that that
doesn't happen
and police departments across the
country but it does happen in some
places and obviously Chicago was one of
them I hope it's no longer like that
well what did happen to former officer
was former officer watts was in 2012 he
was he and one of his officers were
actually arrested when they ripped off a
local drug courier he got 22 months just
22 months in prison for that but neither
he nor anybody else on his team has ever
been charged with what happened to those
so far 60 people who have been
exonerated and the number continues to
grow we'll never know how many Shannon
have any regrets well I'm sure she
regrets losing her career but she
doesn't regret coming forward and the
great thing
thank you Alex always good to have you
hysterical happy we appreciate it we do
and you have one of the best voices Alex
Ferrera I love listening to your tracks
you can watch the season 2 premiere of
whistleblower Chicago PD breaking the
code of silence at tonight at 8:00 7:00
central right here on CBS